en estas conferencias y cumbres del
medio ambiente ya sean específicamente
sobre el cambio climático la pérdida de
biodiversidad o en esta de lisboa sobre
los océanos y su cuidado el objetivo
indiscutible es la recaudación de dinero
pero con mayor razón en esta conferencia
la financiación es el tema clave ya que
el cuidado y uso sostenible de los
océanos recibe la menor partida de los
fondos sobre esta disparidad entre lo
que se dice y lo que se negocia se
pronunció el director ejecutivo del
fondo mundial para el medio ambiente
irónicamente en este mundo mundo
multilateral pues tenemos problemas de
autismo global ya que por un lado
tenemos esta convención de océanos donde
todo el mundo habla las maravillas que
tenemos que hacer y los avances pero
estos mismos países en este en las
negociaciones serias y duras están en un
conflicto ideológico tremendo uno de los
ecosistemas más importantes para la
salud del océano pero que es el que más
está sufriendo son los arrecifes de
coral pero hoy recibieron buenas
noticias una contribución de 18 millones
de dólares que serán canalizados por el
fondo mundial para los arrecifes de
coral la única entidad que une fondos
privados y públicos para proteger estos
ecosistemas no hay muchos esfuerzos
relacionados a aumentar el área de áreas
protegidas marinas pero si a la misma
vez que aumentamos esa área de
protección no aumentamos los recursos
financieros dedicados para el manejo
dedicados para que las comunidades
realmente puedan
no sólo depender de los recursos sino
que cuidarlos al mismo tiempo no lo
vamos a lograr nuestra meta estos fondos
benefician directamente a américa
latina' que a pesar de que siempre más
conocida por sus ecosistemas terrestres
tiene el segundo recife de coral más
grande del planeta